[Music]  can mud homes help save trees yes they  can especially here in Africa Sahel  region a swelling population has led to  a huge increase in deforestation roofs  are made of imported corrugated iron and  wood that's expensive and doesn't  provide insulation French maison Toma  Gagne and Surrey you know a farmer from  burkina faso rediscovered an ancient  construction technique the nubian vault  [Music]  forests are protected as builders only  use bricks and mortar locally made from  earth and water  it's a cost-effective sustainable way of  building and it creates a market for  local masons the houses are cool in hot  weather and warm on the coldest of  nights more than 2,000 such houses have  been built so far in burkina faso mali  senegal and neighboring countries do you  like that if you are also doing your bit  tell us about it  visit our website or send us a tweet  hashtag doing your bed we share your  stories  [Applause]